because I didn't want to be like my um
like my ancestors and everyone else but
I felt like my only two choices was to
either make it or not I didn't want to
be a celebrity I didn't want to be an
entertainer I wanted to be an artist
it's gonna be too degrading and it's
going to be something that I can't live
with I can't do it she's an American
producer and actress on stage screen and
television her breakthrough film came in
2008 with her role as a supporting
actress in doubt in 2012 she was listed
by time as one of the 100 most
influential people in the world
she's Viola Davis and here is my take on
her top ten rules for success rule
number three is my personal favorite and
make sure to stick around all the way to
the end for some special bonus clips
also as viola's talking if she says
something that's really meaningful to
you really resonates with you please
leave it in the comments below and put
quotes around it so other people can be
inspired as well
enjoy
because I was brought up in such
challenging a such a challenging
situation I think that it required me to
live live a more examined life if I were
to get out I have to dream big there was
no room for failure and so therefore I
couldn't I couldn't go the normal route
um so I found myself at a very young age
living that sort of life because I
didn't want to be like my um like my
ancestors and everyone else who was like
me they were you know everyone was
either alcoholics or they lived in
poverty they accepted their lot in life
and I just felt like I didn't want to
live that way in anybody who wants to
kind of stray from the pack I think has
to lead a more exam in life I did what I
had to do in order to make the dream
work I made the commitment knowing that
it always wasn't going to be a smooth
ride but I felt like my only two choices
was to either make it or not and the
knot wasn't an option so I paid whatever
money I needed to pay for the public
transportation to get to acting school
when I was 15 and I did whatever I had
to do to get my um undergraduate degree
in theatre I did the work and I knew
that there was no skimping on the work
well in third grade
this kid was always teasing me I won't
mention his name but he was always
teasing me calling me you [ __ ] you
black [ __ ] it's just every single day
this is way way back when so so one day
I said I'm going to get him he was a
considered the fastest runner in Central
Falls and I said I'm gonna beat your
butt I'm gonna race you a tree
you're not the fastest running Central
Falls I'm the fastest running Central
Falls I probably flipped him the finger
you know I was I was a vulgar kid too
you know I could give it as much as I
got it
so at recess um we decided to race and
the whole school was involved everybody
in the school heard about it and all the
boys and some of the girls are on his
side just kind of just screaming for him
and I had my three or four friends on my
side and we lived in such abject poverty
I remember that my we wouldn't keep up
the date with the shoes
so my shoes were maybe a size too small
and it was the dead of winter and I
could never I couldn't walk in the shoes
I'd have to stop every two steps take
the shoes off then put the shoes kind of
back on and walk again they hurt my feet
so bad and then my socks were so torn
only top part of my socks were left so I
said how am I gonna race him at recess
but these shoes so I said I'm gonna take
my shoes off take my socks off I'm gonna
take my shoes off in the dead of winter
in the concrete and I raced him and I
beat him and I thought to myself it's
only been recently that thought to
myself that everybody was cheering and
cheering and he was saying you didn't
beat me it was a tie you didn't beat me
I said yes I did yes I did and then I
got in trouble with the teachers for
having my shoes off and um but nobody
noticed that I didn't have any shoes on
and that's it's a metaphor for life
because nobody knows that when you come
to the race you don't come with the same
set of tools as everyone else that even
when you come into the race with a
deficit you still have to run the same
race and that's a metaphor I use for my
career you know that you you can't be
perceived even as the black actress who
doesn't get the same kind of roles as
white actors you got to run the same
race
you got to give the same quality
performances you've got to have the same
standard of excellence even though
people know that you're coming to the
race in a deficit that's just what life
is about you know you know that's all
you have at the end of the day is your
work and your integrity um at all costs
I don't care if it's four scenes in a
movie and I don't care what it is that
you have to infuse it with as much
excellence as you can so when absolutely
when I you know was able to work with
Meryl Streep it was a dream come true
and I knew that I had to step up my game
you know you always get better when you
work with people who are excellent you
almost never get better when you work
with people who are not excellent so
when did that dream hit you if it's
hitting Genesis at five when did it hit
you that you wanted to do this while
Cicely Tyson autobiography of Miss Jane
Pittman when I was seven years old that
was it that was literally I can
absolutely mark it definitively in 128
Washington Street in a rat-infested not
mice infested rat infested condemned
apartment building with almost no
plumbing every once in a while the
plumbing would work no phone lack of
food most of the time no electricity no
hot water but that one it was a sump it
was summertime I believe and we had some
electricity because we ran the wires
through the other apartment we had that
one TV that you put the aluminum foil on
the antenna and I saw magic I saw craft
and that's what I wanted to do I want I
wanted to be an artist mm-hmm I didn't
want to be a celebrity I didn't want to
be an entertainer I wanted to be an
artist because that's what I saw there's
always you always have to have a
boundary as an actor for me you are not
gonna see me naked
I'm not gonna get naked
i I've turned down a lot of money to get
naked for this one television show that
actually never made it but um because I
said I'm not going to be able to live
with this if this is kind of preserved
and sell your Lord forever
um but you always have to have a
boundary of what you will or will not do
now your boundary is different from my
boundary because it's like you start you
weigh your choices and for me if it's
going to be - degrading and it's gonna
be something that I can't live with I
can't do it I can't do it and even I
can't even do a lot of roles where I
cuss a lot I have to do an audition
right there really really I mean but it
was extraordinary amount of cussing I
just couldn't do it and I don't feel
like I'm that puritanical but it's just
too much for me
so if you don't have any boundaries then
you're gonna be a puppet you know and at
the same time you have to live with
yourself at the end of the day you know
that's something that actors people we
do a lot because we want it so bad so
we're willing to do anything to get it
um it's good to have boundaries I think
it's really good I know that acting is
not rocket science but it is an art form
and what I find that as the time has
gone on that people have kind of
forgotten that it's an art form I had a
guy who drove my husband and I somewhere
and he said that his brother was an
acting coach and more and more young
people are coming to him and saying just
make me good enough to get the role yeah
and I didn't go in it for that and I'm
not trying to make myself look good
either but when I saw Cicely Tyson do
Jane Pittman I wanted to be a crafts
person I really understood that it was a
craft that I wanted to transform in
every role I wanted to be brave and now
it's gotten harder to do that when
especially as your profile raises it
gets hard
I mean I don't mean this on confusing
when you talk to most actors they will
tell you about it's what I've always
wanted to do love acting and I do love
acting but it's like any commitment you
have periods where you fall out of love
with it and along your journey as an
actor there's so many moments you fall
out of love with it that you you wonder
you forget why you wanted to do it and
you wonder if this was really what you
meant to do but basically it is a love I
guess I think along the way I've
questioned the commitment so those
moments of questioning come when you're
doing work that's not as interesting or
they come even when you're doing the
Delian interesting stuff they come when
I'm not doing things that are
interesting they come when I'm doing
something interesting I think and it's
not received well they come when the
business strangles my love of it those
are the moments that it comes and you
forget why you love it you do and
sometimes the memory lapse can last a
long time and then you think okay
there's got to be something else it's
going to come in it that just comes in
my life that's going to wake me up in
the morning um that's the journey of an
actor though I I guess that's what it is
I think what anything you love becomes a
job mmm it hurts yeah doesn't have that
same and you know when you when you I
mean obviously a lot of people just go
through the life working for the weekend
as the song says the exam but if you
have things you're passionate about that
you're working for that you know
examining and finding it again he has
this challenge we all go through a nice
little session over
and I guess that's that's what it is I
went through that long kind of diatribe
but really it's no good but really
that's what it is you you you you
question the passion you you you know
it's like any commitment you got to work
on the passion to you got to work to
keep bring the passion back with doubt
which might be the first time that
people in film necessarily really
appreciated what you were doing your
preparation for that was a strong
astronomical amazing and so that is the
last pre-health question if I can just
ask you just to show the kind of work
that you're willing to do for even I
think it was eight minutes of screen
time which was deservedly rewarded with
an Oscar nomination but I mean that is
not a ton to work with and yet you made
the most of it how did you what did you
do to prepare for that one um well it's
based on a play so I read the play after
I've read the play I said I don't even
understand this woman I don't know why
this got all this attention this woman
wants a sacrifice her son and
da-da-da-da-da and I had all the kind of
responses that you would have with
character that you didn't understand but
it's being an actor you have to do
investigative work you have to you have
to make sure that when people are in the
audience they understand you and they
they ultimately feel something and so I
had to write a bio which ended up being
over a hundred pages I talked to people
who had seen the play because I was
doing a play at the same time and never
saw the play I read the script probably
I don't know how many times so I
literally study the script for four
months before I finally got it like I
had the aha moment and aha moment is we
always want to feel that decisions are
pretty we always want to believe that
decisions are easy and sometimes they're
a Sophie's Choice you know and sometimes
a person's motivations or absol
lutely pure but to the outside eye they
look very dysfunctional and I probably
you know had the aha moment two days
before I even started filming and I was
really waiting for that aha moment cuz I
said I'm gonna be opposite Meryl Streep
and she's gonna tell me a new a-hole and
I do not want to look bad so um but I
had that aha moment but I did my I did
my work with that I can't emphasize that
enough you know because I I never want
anyone to dismiss my talent listen I
make it up on this screen and there are
times when I may stink because it's
occupational hazard
to not always be good but I never want
anyone to say that she's not an actress
I'm an artist I consider myself to be an
artist
first and foremost and when I was given
Annalise Keating I tell the story a lot
that I saw the pilot and I was horrified
cuz you know you got to look at yourself
with my lashes and my you know little
chubby waist that I thought was very
chubby waist and I didn't look the way I
thought I would look I had an idea in my
head when I thought of the adjectives
sexy dynamic mysterious you know and I
didn't see sexy dynamic mysterious you
know I need it we did the run but no but
no but what I'm leading to is I I said
why not and I think that that's where it
all begins
is that question of why not why can't I
be sexy I reject the notion in the past
that dark-skinned women cannot be
beautiful I reject the fact that if I
take my wig off and do a whole scene
with my fro that somehow that that is
taboo I reject the fact that I have to
be a size two I reject the fact that I
have to be likable I'd rather be
interesting
by the ass you know Robert De Niro in
taxi driver James Gandolfini or you know
or Anthony Hopkins that there you know
dude were you concern that you will like
a bull in Silence of the Lambs unit that
somehow you but somehow you have to
reject all the things that people have
told you you were and I think it starts
there that's amazing and I don't think
you know who can follow that I don't
think it on that note
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Cheryl Chapman
asked me to so if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave in the comments below and
I'll see what I can do I'd also love to
know what was the most impactful part of
this video for you what lesson resonated
the most with you and you're going to
carry that forward into your life in
your business please leave it in the
comments below I'm going to join in the
discussion I also want to give a quick
shout out to Davina Lyons thank you so
much for picking up a copy of my book
your one word it really really really
means a lot to me so thank you guys
again for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
I'll see you soon
in my mind I see a line and over that
line I see green fields and lovely
flowers and beautiful white women with
their arms stretched out to me over that
line but I can't seem to get there know
how I can't seem to get over that line
that was Harriet Tubman in the 1800s and
let me tell you something the only thing
that separates women of color from
anyone else is opportunity
you cannot win an Emmy for roles that
are simply not there so here's to all
the writers the awesome people that have
been shoreward Pauline Peter Nowak
Shonda Rhimes people who have redefined
what it means to be beautiful to be sexy
to be a leading woman to be black and to
the taraji P Henson's the Kerry
Washington's the Halle Berry's the
Nicole Maharis the Megan Goods to
Gabrielle Union thank you for taking us
over that line thank you for the
television Academy thank you what is
there but a dream you can't trade in
your dream for another dream I am so
proud to be back there and I think the
Screen Actors Guild for this award
and I have a special special note to the
kids in Central Falls Rhode Island and
Segway Institute of learning in Central
Falls Rhode Island to dream big and
dream fierce thank you very much so my
question is Senator trucco did you have
Trisha Stanley murdered
are you out of your mind Your Honor this
is going on long enough you convince
your tenant Linda Morelli to testify the
Trisha Stanley was killed by her
boyfriend David Allen way off base I
recommend you rein this in explain why
your eviction suit against miss Morelli
was dropped despite her inability to pay
rate is it because her lost rent money
was nothing compared to the millions you
made once miss Stanley was out of your
way
answer the question senator I was Linda
Morelli granted these concessions to
Chief Justice I have extended great
deference to the court by showing up
here today but I am NOT gonna put up
with this any longer I'm sorry senator
if you do not have the time to answer
for who bore the real cost of your
developer instruction not just Trisha
Stanley and her boyfriend David Allen
who served 21 years and drew runner
pulling for the thousands who were
displaced in the name of lightning your
caucus TV majority who were poor
powerless and didn't bear the color of
skin desirable to your business and your
tour a community apart knew Tony Allen's
order you destroyed lives
admit it miss unless you killed Trisha
Stanley and had my client David Allen
setup for her murder that is enough you
hear me you say another word they'll
have no choice but to throw you in jail
beneath a dozen more me and Eileen done
asked everybody we know 31 maze y'all
too scared think we crazy well if we
don't get more we're not getting
published
I got splitting Stowers mosquito just
write them down and invent them a
deserted y'all ready make it up name
just make up the maze - we're not gonna
do that
that would be wrong don't give up on
this mosquito it wouldn't be real they
kill my son
he fell carrying two about fours at the
mill truck all over him crushes along
the wife woman threw his body on back of
a truck drove to the color Hospital
don't land honk the horn
there was nothing they could do so I
brought my baby home laid him down
that's over right now he died right in
front of me
he's just 24 years old miss Kay the best
part of a person's life anniversary of
his death come every year I can't
breathe but the yawl is just another day
abridge you stop this everything I wrote
he wrote everything he was gonna die
with them